que oui elle gérait il était un membre
est qu un mathieu à cinq ans ce matin
comme tous les jours ils avaient pris le
bus pour aller à l'école à 9h sa maman
recevait un coup de fil rassurant mais
il fallait aller chercher le petit
garçon sur les lieux de l'accident m'a
dit d'attendre un petit peu pour la
prise en charge avec le psychologue et
puis que les gendarmes marque aussi le
nom de chaque enfant qui était bien avec
leurs parents
et puis ensuite on et rentre à la maison
et on a écrit tout de suite il a fallu
écrire tous les nazis mathieu a écrit
des mercis il aurait pu dessiner
l'essentiel que les enfants s'expriment
ce qui était dans le bus mais aussi tous
leurs camarades du regroupement
pédagogique
ils ont été informés dans la matinée il
fallait leur expliquer pourquoi certains
élèves ce matin n'était pas là présent
dû être un petit peu choqué ou plus ou
moins choqué pour certains donc c'est
bien en parler avec tout le monde et
puis tout ça vaut rien de grave c'est
déjà c'est déjà ça y a pas d'enfant de
laisser enfin que légèrement dont ma
fille aurait pu être dans le bus au
center voilà ça fait réfléchir
toute la journée un psychologue scolaire
est resté auprès des élèves un
accompagnement qui va se poursuivre
pendant plusieurs jours s'il ya des
besoins et que le psychologue scolaire
voilà voit que il a des besoins et que
d'autres enfants ne peuvent pas être
encadrés et d'autres psychologues
scolaires pourront éventuellement venir
mais en même temps il faut qu'on arrive
à bien doser parce que la présence de
trop d'adultes peut aussi générer de
l'angoissé
donc nous sommes attentifs aux besoins
exprimés et demain un accompagnement
particulier sera mis en place dans le
bus avec l'équipe éducative est à
nouveau peu psychologue là encore pour
rassurer